winter fly chez nec tout croisés avec
des rollers aux pieds on retrouve les
sensations du patinage artistique les
mêmes impressions de glisse ou de
vitesse à l'entraînement dans leur
gymnase les membres du club les
nordiques de touraine se prépare
activement pour le wild une tour de ce
week-end
une compétition qui suscite beaucoup
d'espoir sur la deuxième compétition
quand j'ai fait et et roja jour se
battre en championnat
oh et puis même j'espère en super à
l'aise et très haut fond son plaisir
avec 70 compétiteurs venus de toute la
france
les meilleurs patineurs offriront le
spectacle mais aussi l'exemple pour les
jeunes tourangeaux qui prennent très au
sérieux cette compétition vale est
importante parce que déjà social club
donc là d'en gagner surtout ma mère
et aussi parce que c'est une compétition
une étoile et que ça va rapporter des
points dans le classement mondial
je mets faire
slalom et peut-être du speed et bah
c'est important pour moi parce que c'est
ma première compétition
cette compétition réunira des
disciplines plus spectaculaires les unes
que les autres avec le salom la vitesse
et en hauteur comme en longueur le saut
les sauts sont vachement intéressant
parce que on va avoir normalement du
très beau monde on va avoir des numéros
1 et 2 bien classés enfin bien classé
pour pour représenter la discipline on
va avoir aussi donc sur le slam
classique des représentants de l'équipe
de france donc ils vont venir patiner
montrer un petit peu ce qu'ils savent
faire et ça permet aussi effectivement
aux enfants de s'identifier de et de se
dire ah j'aimerais faire ça le club
compte beaucoup sur le spectacle de
cette compétition pour voir grossir le
nombre de ses pratiquants
[Musique]
tu prépares à l'afrique